tonight we're learning new details from
one of the women accusing new york
governor andrew cuomo of sexual
misconduct and
we're also getting reaction to a story
we told you last night
about the alleged cover-up of death
statistics in nursing homes during the
pandemic
correspondent brian yennis reports
tonight from brooklyn
to see the facts come out it's just
shocking
tonight outrage from nursing home
victims families over documents obtained
by fox news
that show since mid april 2020 the cuomo
administration was specifically tracking
how many residents died of covet-19 in
nursing homes
and how many residents later died in
hospitals the documents raised new
questions
about why the state's department of
health chose to exclude the hospital
deaths from their july 2020 report
despite having this data for months the
report
said 6400 new yorkers died in nursing
homes but the true death toll was 9 800
including hospital deaths the cuomo
administration said
the hospital deaths weren't made public
because they could not verify
the data doh said in part the department
spent months reconciling the information
received
deduplicating correcting data entry
errors etc
in order to understand and report
accurate fatality data
from multiple sources but the new york
times and wall street general report
cuomo's top aides purposely excluded the
true death count from the report
over fears of political consequences for
the governor
meantime a current aide who says cuomo
aggressively sexually groped her
is speaking out for the first time
telling the albany times union
it was the culmination of two years of
grooming it's the most serious known
sexual harassment allegation
against cuomo the state attorney general
is investigating all allegations
she could analyze it and determine that
there is probable cause to bring some
sort of a criminal conduct
action against the governor the unnamed
groping accuser has not filed a criminal
complaint against cuomo
though the ag could move forward with
the case regardless
shannon brian yenis in new york thank
you brian
up next the panel on president biden's
gun control